let's take a look at the most recent
issue of Reason magazine with recent
editor-in-chief Matt Welch great cover
art which we'll get to in just a little
bit but it's all about the apocalypse
the fiscal cliff what do we learn with
this comprehensive coverage come January
first or second as the case may be we're
going to be jacking up taxes we're going
to come up with some kind of short-term
deal that does nothing to cut spending
that will do very very little in the
best-case scenario to actually do
anything about the deficit probably
won't touch entitlements and will keep
in place the same kind of system of
kicking the can down the road having
crisis to crisis short-term kind of
management that have god has gotten us
into this trouble to begin with we
haven't had a budget since 2009 I mean
it's a basic kind of oversight that you
would expect Congress to do they were
supposed to initiate spending instead
they initiate deadlines they it's a debt
ceiling today so we have to come up with
some kind of cobble together the last
minute thing the types of legislation
that they're passing has a lot of well
we're going to fix the rules later
someone else is going to write the rules
later the if there is a negotiated
settlement on the stuff it's going to be
will cut government ten years down the
road entitlements it's a promise it's
not an actual plan and speaking of
entitlement spending cuts it's almost
impossible to cut military spending and
that's the other end of the budget
veronique de rugy wrote very differently
about it it's impossible to cut defense
spending right now Republicans
particularly are freaked out about the
sequestration cuts that might slow the
growth in defense spending Mitt Romney
was freaking out about it everyone's
freaking out of the smallest Navy since
the Village People um but let me ask you
this because libertarians are normally
very excited about privatization why is
privatizing and subcontracting so bad
for the military it's not necessarily
bad for the military maybe we'd be
spending a lot more than we would be
otherwise but the problem is you've
created an entire class of people who
are trying to Goose even more government
spending and who can portray every
single proposed imagine a reduction in
the future as cutting defense to the
bone and jeopardizing us you know to the
jihad ease and let's talk about the
government spying on you Ron Bailey
writes about that I'm the government has
been asking the federal government
asking cell phone providers hey give us
the records the geolocation data
of all of your users or whatever users
that we asked so in 2011 1.5 million
requests the government made of
individuals local police departments are
saying ok do this it's great you know we
don't even need warrants anymore but
let's do this and make sure not to make
a big deal out of it because if the
public knew they might freak out about
it so this thing has gone from zero to a
hundred in about a year and a half yeah
they literally have talking points it's
say don't tell the media how close we
can get and how much we can gather from
cell phone data so it's our job as the
media to tell everybody else tell me
about the cover art this is a fantastic
and reminds me of a tattoo I should get
this is a the great la artists coupe
who's done a bunch of punk rock posters
and album covers Nirvana Soundgarden
reverend horton heat and that kind of
stuff and we just said hey give us a
skeletal deaf man he's a guy you might
know from like devil guys and devil
babes everywhere he has a very
identifiable style and that I'm very
tickled to have him on the cover oh well
done Matt Walter editor-in-chief of
Reason magazine go pick it up on
newsstands now thanks man Thank You Man
thank you for reason TV I'm Kennedy
you